.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich frage mich, wie ich das
so lange aushalten konnte.
Wie habe ich das
bloss durchgestanden?
Damals musste ich es einfach.
Dass man einem Kind
so etwas antun kann -
auf diese Frage werde ich wohl nie
eine Antwort erhalten.
Es gab stets dieses imaginäre
Gesetzbuch, das es zu befolgen galt.
Auch ich hätte meine Kinder erziehen
und schlagen sollen.
Und wenn der Wille des Kindes
bis zum Alter von drei Jahren
nicht gebrochen war, war es zu spät.
In diesem Film erzählen
junge Menschen erstmals offen
über ihr Leben
in einer evangelikalen Gemeinde,
die eng verknüpft ist
mit dem Chocolatier Jürg Läderach.
Der erfolgreiche Unternehmer
hat sich in einer kleinen Gemeinde,
im sankt-gallischen Kaltbrunn,
eine evangelikale Welt erschaffen,
mit einer Freikirche und Schule.
Die Läderachs waren die perfekte
Familie, eine Vorzeigefamilie.
Nach aussen wirkten sie nicht so,
als dass da Gewalt
im Spiel gewesen wäre.
Meine Strafe war, zuzuschauen,
wie meine Schulkollegen
geschlagen wurden.
Und von wem wurden sie geschlagen?
Von Herrn Läderach, Jürg Läderach.
Ein Untersuchungsbericht hält fest:
In der evangelikalen Welt wurden
Kinder mutmasslich missbraucht -
"in religiöser, psychischer,
körperlicher und sexueller Hinsicht".
Jürg Läderach selbst
bestreitet jegliche Gewalt.
Die Betroffenen blieben bisher anonym
und reden nun erstmals
über eine bislang verborgene Welt.
Läderach.
Ein Name,
der für Schokolade und Erfolg steht.
Jürg Läderach hat ein welt-
umspannendes Unternehmen aufgebaut
und war bis vor ein paar Jahren
Patron der Schokoladen-Firma.
Der Name "Jürg Läderach" steht
für Schokolade. Läuft das Geschäft?
Ja, das Geschäft läuft,
weil unser Konzept einmalig ist.
Voraussetzung dafür sind aber
Standorte mit hoher Kaufkraft.
Wir sind in München, Stras...
- Baden-Baden.
Genau, in Stuttgart haben wir soeben
einen Laden eröffnet.
Es müssen Standorte
mit hoher Kaufkraft sein.
Der Name "Läderach" wird heute auch
in Verbindung gebracht mit Homophobie
und dem Kampf gegen die Abtreibung.
2019 wird publik:
Jürg Läderach und sein Sohn Johannes
engagierten sich im Vorstand
in einer
der zehn Trägerorganisationen
für den "Marsch fürs Läbe".
Der "Marsch fürs Läbe",
ein Manifest gegen die Abtreibung
nach amerikanischem Vorbild.
Seither sind die Läderach-Filialen
immer wieder Schauplatz
für Gegendemonstrationen.
Läderach verkauft nebst Schokolade
offenbar auch christliche Werte.
Der Inhaber Jürg Läderach
ist gegen die Gleichstellung
und engagiert sich als Moralapostel
gegen Homosexuelle.
Die Firma Läderach führen heute
die Söhne von Jürg Läderach.
Sie betonen ihre Offenheit,
allen Menschen gegenüber.
* Applaus *
Ich bin ein christlich liberaler,
weltoffener und entspannter Mensch.
Bei Läderach gibt es alle möglichen
Meinungen zu allen möglichen Themen.
Wir sind das diverseste Unternehmen,
denn wir haben auch
"diversity of opinion".
Chocolate is inclusive,
chocolate is for everybody.
Chocolate is about
charing the joy
of chocolate made fresh.
Das ist unser Purpose.
Ein wenig bekanntes Reich
von Jürg Läderach:
Der Hof Oberkirch im sankt-gallischen
Kaltbrunn, nahe bei Rapperswil-Jona.
Jürg Läderach baute hier
mit Gleichgesinnten
eine evangelikale Privatschule auf.
Sie nennen sie "Domino Servite",
"Dienet dem Herrn" -
eine Schule
für Kinder bis zur Oberstufe.
Auch die sechs Kinder von Läderachs
gingen hier zur Schule.
An der Oberstufe
unterrichtete Esther Läderach,
sie war zudem in der Schulleitung.
Auf dem gleichen Areal
entstand eine Freikirche.
"Evangelische Gemeinde
Hof Oberkirch" heisst sie heute.
Jürg Läderach ist hier Onkel Jürg,
der Laienprediger.
Wir wollen noch einmal beten,
bevor wir Gottes Wort lesen.
Wir danken Dir, Herr Jesus,
dass Du es uns ermöglicht hast,
einander zu stärken.
Wir sehen die Kraft, die darin ist.
* Chorgesang,
begleitet von Klaviermusik *
Ich liebe Jesus.
Er liebt uns,
aber bringt uns die Wahrheit.
Er ist unkäuflich -
mir gegenüber, dir gegenüber,
einem jeden Menschen gegenüber.
Aber er liebt uns.
Und er ...
... heilt uns.
* Klaviermusik *
Die Schule auf dem Hof Oberkirch
hoch über Kaltbrunn
heisst seit vier Jahren
"Christliche Schule Linth".
Die Kinder sollen hier zur Ehrfurcht
vor dem dreieinigen Gott
erzogen werden.
Ins Gebäude hinein dürfen wir nicht.
Stattdessen soll uns ihr Medien-
sprecher auf dem Areal herumführen.
Den Sportplatz hier
gab es schon damals.
... zum Haupteingang der Schule.
Wir gehen später noch runter -
dort, wo die Kinder hineinkommen.
Das Schulhaus gibt es schon
seit den 1920er-Jahren.
Das ist das Hauptgebäude?
Ja, genau. Und unten
gibt es noch einen Pavillon.
Aber das hier ist die Schule?
- Ja, genau.
Im Parterre und in der ersten Etage,
und oben sind Wohnungen.
Das ist der Eingang für die Kinder.
Und was ist das hier?
Ein Wohnhaus. Früher hat hier
ein Teil der Kinder übernachtet.
Das war also das Internat?
- Ja, genau.
Sowie in den oberen beiden Etagen
des Schulhauses.
Auf dem Hof werden aktuell
48 Kinder unterrichtet.
Joel hat die Schule
Mitte der 1990er-Jahre besucht.
Wir sind 1995 aus dem Kanton Bern
nach Kaltbrunn gezogen,
als die Schule eröffnet wurde.
Joel ist sechs Jahre alt,
als er mit seinen neun Geschwistern
und seinen Eltern
in den Kanton St. Gallen zieht.
Der Hof Oberkirch in Kaltbrunn
wird geistige Heimat für seine Eltern
und damit auch für Joel.
Dort hat alles begonnen,
die gesamte Schulzeit auf dem Hof.
Gottesdienste, Freizeit ...
... arbeiten.
Joel war insgesamt elf Jahre
in der Schule auf dem Hof Oberkirch.
Ich war manchmal ein Schlingel,
ich hatte immer Unsinn im Kopf,
Streiche machen und so.
Einmal habe ich im Internat einem
Gspänli den Weg aufs WC versperrt
und er machte in die Hose.
Dann gab es Schläge.
"Das macht man nicht."
Und wie wurde geschlagen?
Mit dem Gurt.
Manchmal mit dem Gurt,
manchmal mit der Gurtschnalle.
Man musste sich übers Bett bücken,
die Hose runterlassen
und dann gab es Schläge,
bis man sich irgendwie mit dem Kopf
aus dem Körper gemogelt hat,
damit man gar nicht mehr dort ist
und es nicht mehr spürt.
Und es endete nicht
nach zwei, drei Schlägen,
es ging so lange weiter, bis ...
Wenn du in diesen Raum musstest,
wusstest du, was folgt.
Es war eigentlich
eine schöne Wohnung,
die dem Internatsleiter gehörte.
Ein weisser, heller Raum
mit gotischen Schnörkeleien
und einem schönen Kronleuchter.
Und dann das Bett, das dastand.
Man wusste genau:
Es sah zwar schön aus, aber ...
... in dem Raum
gab es gar nichts Schönes.
Und wer hat geschlagen?
Einerseits der Internatsleiter
Hans Koller,
andererseits seine Frau,
Helga Koller.
Das ehemalige Knabeninternat.
Gleich nebenan
wohnte Pfarrer Hans Koller
mit seiner Frau
und seinen Kindern.
Er und seine Frau leiteten damals
das Knabeninternat gemeinsam.
Hans Koller,
ein evangelischer Pfarrer,
war zudem Schulleiter
und Leiter der Freikirche.
(Hans Koller) Der Satan wartet nur,
dass deine Reservation oben
dir nichts mehr bedeutet.
Und wenn sie dir
nichts mehr bedeutet,
dann hast du im nächsten Augenblick
deinen Stammplatz und deinen Namen
in der Hölle reserviert.
Hans Koller Ð
ein Weggefährte von Jürg Läderach.
Die beiden machten den Hof Oberkirch
damals zum Hauptsitz
ihrer religiösen Bewegung.
Helga Koller,
die ehemalige Internatsleiterin,
bestätigt uns heute,
sie habe damals Kinder geschlagen.
Sie wird in unserem Film
noch ausführlicher darüber reden.
Wir fragen auch bei Hans Koller nach:
"Haben Sie Kinder geschlagen?"
Darauf gibt er, auch auf mehrmaliges
Nachfragen, keine Antwort.
Er bestreitet jedoch,
als angeblicher "Haupttäter"
oder überhaupt als "Haupttäter"
schuldig zu sein.
Wer alles wusste davon?
Bezüglich der Schläge
und all dieser Dinge -
das wussten alle,
das war kein Geheimnis.
Alle, die in der Leitung waren:
die Lehrer, der Gemeindeleiter ...
Man wusste einfach,
dass Kinder geschlagen werden.
Das wurde ja auch gepredigt.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass man es nicht wusste,
wir wurden ja so oft geschlagen.
Auch ich, täglich -
so was kriegt man mit.
Ich wurde ja auch
im Lehrerzimmer geschlagen.
Damals waren sie Kinder und hilflos.
Jetzt, als Erwachsene, wagen sie,
offen darüber zu reden.
Ich musste meistens über einen Stuhl
oder übers Knie liegen,
Hose und Unterhose runterziehen
und dann gab es Schläge.
Danach durfte ich wieder
spielen gehen oder was auch immer.
Und womit wurden Sie geschlagen?
Mit allem Möglichen.
Meistens mit Gürteln,
die sie getragen haben.
Das wussten alle Kinder:
Wenn man still ist,
keinen Ton von sich gibt,
sich ruhig hinlegt, dann ist das
in drei bis vier Schlägen durch.
Wenn man aufbegehrt,
dann wird man geschlagen,
bis man aufhört zu weinen,
bis es still ist.
Und ich habe relativ schnell
die Taktik angewendet:
Wenn ich still bin,
dann ist es schnell vorbei.
Als wir vor über zwei Jahren
mit den Recherchen beginnen,
geben die Verantwortlichen
kurz darauf
eine eigene Untersuchung in Auftrag.
Ihr Bericht liegt nun vor
und listet auf, was wir zuvor schon
von betroffenen Schüler/-innen
erfahren haben:
Es ist von Schlägen aller Art
die Rede, von Schlagritualen.
Davon, dass sich Kinder dabei nackt
oder halbnackt ausziehen mussten.
Es kam mutmasslich
zu sexuellen Grenzüberschreitungen
und zu Missbrauch.
Mit den damals Verantwortlichen
konnten wir nie direkt reden,
sondern ausschliesslich mit ihren
Mediensprechern und Anwälten.
Die Verantwortlichen von damals
sind hauptsächlich:
der Chocolatier Jürg Läderach,
Pfarrer Hans Koller
und drei Laienprediger.
Die fünf haben damals, 1995, den Hof
Oberkirch mit anderen übernommen.
Sie waren hier die "Onkels", sie
leiteten Schule, Internat und Kirche.
Die Kinder wurden ihnen
seelsorgerisch anvertraut.
Denn die fünf
waren auch Seelsorger und Prediger.
Eine Gemeinde, die kein Gebet hat -
kann eine Gemeinde bestehen
ohne Gebet?
Das Gebet ist doch das Verhäl...
... die Gemeinschaft.
Beten und beichten. Das hatte nach
der Lehre am Hof Oberkirch Priorität.
Wer das nicht tat,
dem drohte die Hölle.
Für Kinder wie Joel
eine Welt des Misstrauens,
der Angst und absoluten Kontrolle.
Haben Sie Ihren Eltern erzählt,
wie es Ihnen in der Schule ging?
Nein.
Das tat ich nur einmal,
und das hatte
eine doppelte Strafe zur Folge,
weil sie leider damals
hinter dem ganzen System standen.
Darum habe ich nichts erzählt.
Ich habe es für mich behalten.
Man konnte niemandem vertrauen?
- Nein.
Und dem Seelsorger?
- Diesem erst recht nicht.
Ich habe das getestet.
In die Seelsorge ging man ja,
damit man offiziell
ein göttliches Leben lebt.
Ich machte es, um gut dazustehen:
dass alle sehen,
ich gehe in die Seelsorge.
Manchmal erzählte ich Dinge,
die nicht stimmten,
und dann wurde ich dafür
zu Hause bestraft.
Da wusste ich:
Da gibt es eine undichte Stelle,
die kommunizieren miteinander.
Das ist keine Seelsorge,
der erzählt weiter.
Wer war Ihr Seelsorger?
Am Anfang war es ...
Wie hiess er nochmals ...
Zuerst war es* Piepston *,
und danach Jürg Läderach.
Auf den Hof Oberkirch
kamen kaum Aussenstehende.
Wer sich hier bewegte,
gehörte in der Regel dazu.
Das galt für die meisten Lehrerinnen
und Lehrer, genauso für die Eltern.
Es war ein in sich
geschlossenes System,
in dem für die Kinder
ein Gefühl dominierte:
Angst.
Schule und Familie,
das war eine grosse Gemeinschaft.
Die Lehrerinnen waren deine Tanten
oder deine Gotte,
du warst bei ihnen
zum Abendessen ...
Schule, Predigt, Glaube, Familie Ð
das konnte man nicht trennen,
das war eine grosse Gemeinschaft,
man war vernetzt.
Im Untersuchungsbericht ist von einer
Theologie der Angst die Rede,
einer Verhörpraxis
und einem Bekennungsdruck
und einer Kultur der Denunziation,
der Manipulation und der Drohungen.
Die Kinder wurden hinter
verschlossenen Türen geschlagen.
Meine Eltern
sagten das auch immer klar:
Das dürfe nicht nach aussen dringen,
weil sie sonst dafür
ins Gefängnis kommen könnten.
Es war wie klar,
dass das von Gott so gewollt ist
und sie es deshalb tun,
aber nicht vor dieser Welt.
Also darf man es
nicht weitererzählen.
Wenn mein kleiner Bruder
geschlagen wurde,
mussten wir jeweils Klavier spielen,
damit man seine Schreie
draussen nicht hörte.
Wurden die Kinder der Familie
Läderach auch gezüchtigt?
Ja, absolut.
Das habe ich selbst mitbekommen,
ich bin als Kind
bei ihnen ein und aus gegangen.
Beim Abendessen
durften die Kinder nicht reden,
da galt absolutes Stillschweigen.
Auch sie hat mitgemacht.
Esther Läderach.
Sie wurden
von Esther Läderach gezüchtigt?
Ja, unter anderem.
Esther Läderach bestreitet dies
und lässt notariell festhalten,
dass sie nie Schüler/-innen
geschlagen oder misshandelt habe,
auch nicht ihre eigenen Kinder.
Ein gleiches Dokument lässt uns
auch Jürg Läderach zukommen:
Er versichert an Eides statt,
dass er niemals Schüler/-innen
geschlagen oder misshandelt habe.
Beide betonen: Missbrauch, Gewalt
und Diskriminierung
seien mit ihrem christlichen Glauben
nicht vereinbar.
Während unserer Recherchen
lässt uns Jürg Läderach
über seinen Vertreter wissen:
Wer künftig behaupte,
er habe geschlagen,
wer derartige unwahre Behauptungen
aufstelle,
dem werde Strafanzeige gestellt.
* Stumme Szene *
Nach wie vor will niemand
vor der Kamera Stellung nehmen,
stattdessen soll dies
der Mediensprecher übernehmen.
Wir fragen ihn: Hat man nichts
gewusst von den Züchtigungen?
Nein, nicht nichts gewusst.
Es war ein Teilwissen,
nicht alle wussten alles.
Das Ergebnis der Untersuchung
hat die Leute erschüttert,
ja schockiert.
Das hatte man so nicht erwartet.
Und überrascht es Sie,
wenn ich Ihnen sage,
dass die Betroffenen mir berichteten,
dass alle geschlagen haben?
Ich kann nicht
für die Einzelnen sprechen.
Einige sagen,
sie haben nie geschlagen,
und andere geben zu,
geschlagen zu haben.
Von den fünf sagt W. M., er erinnere
sich an drei Fälle im Schulbereich,
wo er geschlagen habe.
C. M. wollte nicht Stellung nehmen.
Die anderen bestreiten,
geschlagen zu haben.
In Briefen entschuldigen sich
Jürg Läderach, O. V. und W. M.
bei den Betroffenen für das Unrecht,
das ihnen in der Vergangenheit
angetan wurde.
Sie schreiben von Scham
und von ihrer Betroffenheit.
Zeichen seien nicht
wahrgenommen worden,
man hätte vor Jahren handeln müssen.
Sie bitten um Verzeihung.
Die Elite
entschuldigt sich für etwas,
das sie quasi nicht gesehen haben,
aber sie entschuldigen sich nicht
dafür, dass sie dabei mitmachten.
Und sie haben mitgemacht,
jeder Einzelne von ihnen.
Und die Unterzeichner
waren die Schlimmsten von allen.
Sie haben
an vorderster Front mitgemacht.
Die südafrikanische Mission
Kwasizabantu.
Sie war die religiöse Heimat für
Jürg Läderach und seine Weggefährten.
* Er spricht eine Fremdsprache. *
Der evangelikale Missionar
Erlo Stegen.
Ihm folgen weltweit
schätzungsweise 40'000 Menschen.
Erlo Stegen
soll sich als Gesandter Gottes sehen
und verspricht Erweckung und Wunder.
She says, "It's so wonderful, Lord
Jesus, that you've set me free."
Mein Wunsch und Gebet sind,
dass Gott zum Ziele kommt.
Warum kannst du dem Teufel folgen?
Was bietet er dir?
Was bekommst du daraus?
Jürg Läderach und seine Frau Esther.
Für sie waren der Missionar Erlo
Stegen und dessen Bruder Friedel
langjährige Wegbegleiter.
Auch familiär
haben sie sich verbunden:
Von den sechs Läderach-Kindern
sind drei mit Nachkommen von
Missionar Friedel Stegen verheiratet.
* Chorgesang *
# Halleluja.
* Applaus, Jubel *
Jürg Läderach und seine Weggefährten
brachten die südafrikanische Mission
in den 1990er-Jahren in die Schweiz.
Der Hof Oberkirch wurde Hauptsitz
und ihre Freikirche hiess fortan
"Kwasizabantu Schweiz".
Bereits zu dieser Zeit
warnten deutsche Theologen
vor den südafrikanischen Missionaren.
Sie berichteten
von physischer Brutalität,
von Missbrauch und
von sektenhaften Verhaltensweisen.
Jürg Läderach und seine Weggefährten
blieben der Sekte treu.
Erst 2019 wenden sie sich ab,
benennen ihre Freikirche um
und predigen seither
unter neuem Namen.
Die Engländer haben
ein schönes Lied, wo es heisst:
# Into my heart.
# Come into my heart, Lord Jesus.
Ende der 1990er-Jahre
wurden auf dem Hof in Kaltbrunn
knapp 100 Kinder unterrichtet.
In der Domino Servite Schule,
wie sie damals noch hiess,
mit dem Ziel, Kinder
auf den göttlichen Weg zu bringen.
Auch Joel und seine Geschwister
wurden dort eingeschult.
Alle, ausser Marianne.
Wo ich da auf dem Foto bin?
Hier.
Marianne
ist die Älteste der zehn Kinder.
Für sie gab es damals
noch keine Oberstufe.
Der sonntägliche Gottesdienst auf dem
Hof war jedoch auch für sie Pflicht.
Und nach einem solchen passierte es:
Die damals 15-Jährige
wurde vergewaltigt.
Am 6. April 1996.
Ich weiss das Datum noch genau.
Ich war verliebt
in einen der Schüler.
Dort, wo jetzt die Kirche ist,
war früher ein Schwimmbad
samt Gartenhäuschen,
das vollgestopft war
mit Decken und anderem.
Und wir gingen da rein.
Meine Vorstellung war,
wir würden uns umarmen und küssen -
was wir natürlich
auch nicht hätten machen dürfen -,
doch er zog gleich
das volle Programm durch.
Er sagte,
wenn ich jetzt schreite,
dann würde es für mich ein Problem
und nicht für ihn.
Er bedrohte mich auch.
Ich bin wie erstarrt und
habe es über mich ergehen lassen.
Ich kann es ja benennen:
Ich wurde vergewaltigt,
von einem jungen Mann,
der auch nicht wusste,
wie damit umgehen, weil man es
uns nicht beigebracht hatte.
Danach ging ich in der Turnhalle
auf die Toilette.
Ich stand völlig unter Schock.
Ich dachte: "Was mache ich jetzt?"
Wo gehe ich jetzt hin?"
"Wem kann ich es erzählen?"
Alles Mögliche.
Ich wusste,
dass ich jetzt Ärger kriege,
weil ich an etwas Verbotenem
beteiligt war.
Erst dann bemerkte ich,
dass ich voller Blut war.
Ich wusste, dass wenn ich jetzt
rausgehe, würden das alle sehen.
Also musste ich in der Toilette
eine Lösung finden,
damit ich rausgehen kann,
als wäre nichts passiert.
Also nahm ich Wasser aus der
Schüssel und wusch mich damit.
Ich habe es dann jemandem erzählt,
und diese Person
hat es offenbar weitergesagt,
Ich wurde dann
zur Seelsorge bestellt.
Ich glaube,
damals war es noch bei Hans Koller.
Dann nahm das Ganze seinen Lauf.
Ich dachte zunächst, vielleicht
würde dann schon mal jemand sagen,
es täte ihnen leid,
dass er mir das angetan habe.
Mit der Zeit
wurde jedoch immer deutlicher,
dass man mir unterstellte,
dass ich das gewollt hätte,
dass es mir Spass gemacht hätte.
Man hat mir nicht geglaubt.
Es war wie klar,
dass Sie die Verursacherin sind?
Die Hure.
Ja.
Mhm.
Der 15-jährige Schüler
musste danach die Schule verlassen.
Auf eine Anzeige wurde verzichtet.
Auch Marianne wurde bestraft.
Ich wurde
aus der Gemeinschaft ausgeschlossen,
durfte nicht mehr im Chor mitsingen,
bei allem nicht mehr dabei sein.
Es wurde öffentlich verkündet,
dass ich nicht mehr
Teil der Gemeinschaft sei.
Ich durfte noch die Gottesdienste
besuchen, aber sonst nichts mehr.
Keine gemeinsamen Mittagessen,
kein Chor,
mich nicht mit anderen treffen
oder mit anderen etwas unternehmen.
Nach dem Gottesdienst musste ich
ins Auto sitzen und dort essen.
Dort musste ich warten,
bis der Rest der Familie kam
und wir nach Hause gingen.
Aus ihrer Sicht war meine Reinheit
weg, war ich nicht mehr unbefleckt.
Dieser Stempel
wurde mir aufgedrückt.
Ich glaube, es wäre heute noch so,
wenn ich da hingehen würde.
Ich wäre wahrscheinlich noch immer
die Hure von damals.
Selbst jetzt, trotz drei Kinder.
Ihre Eltern, selbst gefangen
in diesem System, fügten sich.
Marianne verlässt den Hof
wenige Jahre später für immer.
Ihre jüngere Schwester Eliane
wird ihr folgen.
Doch zuerst wird sie,
knapp 20-jährig,
mit einem Mann aus der religiösen
Gemeinschaft zusammengeführt.
Ich habe ihn nicht gekannt,
nichts von ihm gewusst.
Die Anfrage kam von ihm.
Er ging zum Seelsorger,
zu Jürg Läderach,
und sagte ihm,
er wolle mich heiraten.
Daraufhin
rief mich Jürg Läderach an
und informierte mich darüber.
Warum ruft Jürg Läderach Sie an,
um Ihnen zu sagen,
dass ein Mann Sie heiraten möchte?
Weil Mann und Frau
nichts miteinander zu reden haben.
Das war strikt getrennt.
Ich sprach nie mit ihm,
nachdem ich wusste,
dass wir uns verloben werden.
Bis zum Entscheid
lief alles nur über Jürg,
und es durfte auch sonst niemand
davon wissen.
Ich durfte
mit niemandem darüber reden.
Ist es üblich,
dass eine Frau gefragt wird
und eine Frau
nicht selbst fragen darf?
Ja. Die Frau wird angefragt
und nicht umgekehrt.
Wann sprachen Sie das erste Mal
mit Ihrem Verlobten?
Das war auf dem Weg von der Kirche,
in der Kutsche.
Unsere erste Berührung war,
als mein Vater mich ihm übergab
und ich mich bei ihm einhakte.
Das war unsere erste Berührung.
Danach, auf dem Weg
von der Kirche zum Festsaal,
haben wir das erste Mal
miteinander gesprochen.
Da waren wir das erste Mal allein
und es kam zum ersten Kuss.
Crazy.
Friedel Stegen,
der Missionar aus Südafrika,
traut die beiden 2009 in Kaltbrunn.
Der Verdacht,
dass Ehen arrangiert würden,
wurde von den Verantwortlichen
stets dementiert:
Im Mai 2000 stellen sie in einem
Schreiben an die Behörde klar:
Keinesfalls würden Ehen
durch Drittpersonen gekoppelt,
unterzeichnet von Hans Koller
und Jürg Läderach.
Auch heute wiederholt Jürg Läderach,
es würden keinesfalls Ehen
gekoppelt werden.
Ich habe von einer Frau gehört,
die mit ihren Schwestern zusammen
für ihren alkoholabhängigen Mann
gebetet hat.
Und der Herr hat ihr Gebet erhört.
Und der Mann wurde frei.
Und er begann, seine Aufgabe ...
... auszufüllen, als Mann im Haus,
als Leiter, als Oberhaupt.
Wie ich hörte,
war das Problem für sie ...
... anscheinend jetzt grösser,
wo er frei war vom Alkohol,
als vorher,
wo sie sozusagen machen konnte,
was sie wollte.
Es gab in der Öffentlichkeit
schon lange Spekulationen,
dass die Kinder auf dem Hof
nicht nur streng erzogen,
sondern mutmasslich
auch geschlagen würden.
1999 wendet sich
ein Aussteiger an die Behörde.
Er schreibt, dass die Kinder
in der Domino Servite Schule
im Hof Oberkirch in Kaltbrunn
gezüchtigt würden.
Er habe Kenntnis davon, dass die
Kinder tatsächlich geschlagen würden.
Der Kanton beauftragte
die regionale Aufsichtsbehörde.
Sie solle vorbeigehen
und die Vorwürfe überprüfen.
Daraufhin meldete die Behörde
ihren Besuch auf dem Hof an.
* Unverständliche Szene *
(Joel W.)
Man hat "Superklassen" gemacht.
D.h., die Personen
von der Aufsichtsbehörde
haben nicht alles angeschaut.
Mich hat man dann
aus der Klasse rausgenommen
und in eine andere gesteckt.
Haben Sie mitgekriegt,
dass die Aufsichtsbehörde mal kam?
Ja, das haben wir mitgekriegt.
Das war immer ein grosses Thema
in der Schule.
Als Schüler
wurde man darauf vorbereitet.
Im Chor haben wir dafür
Lieder eingeübt,
damit wir dann
beim Besuch der Aufsichtsbehörde
schön vorsingen können.
Egal von welcher Behörde -
es war immer ein Schauspiel,
eine Inszenierung.
Nicht echt?
- Nein.
Und wenn es echt gewesen wäre,
was hätten sie gesehen?
Dann hätten sie
die Schule geschlossen, per sofort.
Der Bericht
der regionalen Aufsichtsbehörde
fiel in der Folge positiv aus:
"Es konnten keine Feststellungen
gemacht werden."
"Die Kinder fühlen sich wohl."
Der Kanton
als oberste Aufsichtsbehörde
machte zusätzlich
umfassende Untersuchungen.
Jürg Raschle war damals Leiter des
Rechtsdiensts beim Kanton St. Gallen
und erinnert sich.
Alle hatte Zweifel
und ein ungutes Gefühl,
aber man ist ihnen
nie auf die Schliche gekommen.
In den Akten sieht man,
wie viel unternommen wurde -
mit Visitationen,
mit Berichterstattungen,
mit Arbeitsgruppen ...
Es wurde auch ein unabhängiger
Rechtsanwalt eingeschaltet.
Man hat wirklich darum gerungen,
aber man ist nie über die Schwelle
oder zu der Schwelle gekommen,
wirklich etwas in der Hand zu haben,
um die Schule schliessen zu können.
Eine wesentliche Rolle
spielten die Eltern:
Sie schrieben der Behörde,
dass ihre Kinder
die Schule sehr lieben würden
und sie selbst zu 100 %
hinter diesen Lehrern stünden.
Ausschlaggebend ist,
wie sich die Eltern positionieren.
Sie sind der Schlüssel.
Das wird letztlich auch gewichtet,
wenn nichts Greifbares vorliegt.
Auch Hans Koller und Jürg Läderach
schrieben damals
eine Stellungnahme an den Kanton:
Der Aussteiger wolle sich
an der Schule und Mission rächen,
die Vorwürfe seien klar haltlos.
Aufgrund des Untersuchungsberichts
weiss man, dass zu dieser Zeit
mutmasslich am meisten gezüchtigt
und misshandelt wurde.
Damals haben die Kinder nicht gewagt,
gegen die Schule auszusagen.
20 Jahre später ist das möglich.
So schwarz
habe ich mich dort drinnen gefühlt.
Was hat dieses Schwarze ausgelöst?
Angst, die andauernde Angst.
Die Angst ...
... in die Hölle zu kommen,
Fehler zu machen.
Er ist in der 5. Klasse,
als er auf den Hof,
in die Schule und ins Internat kommt.
Es gab eine Art Status
von "schlagbaren"
und "nicht schlagbaren" Kindern.
Es gab also ein System dahinter,
wie man mit welchem Kind umgeht.
Wurden Sie geschlagen?- Ich war
ein nicht schlagbares Kind.
Er galt als "nicht schlagbar",
weil seine Eltern
nicht der Freikirche angehörten.
Einmal trieben wir Unsinn,
ein paar Jungs und ich.
Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr,
was es war.
Wahrscheinlich sprangen wir während
der Andacht herum und waren laut.
Am nächsten Tag mussten wir
mit Jürg Läderach in ein Zimmer.
Ich könnte genau nachzeichnen,
wie es im Raum aussah.
Im Raum gab es ein Lavabo.
Er sprach mit uns
und wir beteten zusammen.
Und dann ...
Danach züchtigte er die Kinder
mit seinem Gürtel.
Ich könnte
die Gürtelschnalle nachzeichnen -
ich weiss noch genau,
wie sie aussah.
Dann wurden auch die ganzen Regeln
bekannt gegeben:
Also wenn ein Kind
während der Schläge
zu weinen oder zu schreien beginnt,
dass sich die Schläge vermehrfachen.
Danach wurden die Kinder geschlagen,
und meine Strafe war,
dass ich zuschauen musste, wie meine
Schulkollegen geschlagen wurden.
"Haben Sie Kinder geschlagen?",
fragen wir noch einmal nach.
Er habe nie geschlagen
oder misshandelt, betont er erneut.
Er und seine Frau
bäten die Betroffenen
um Verzeihung für das Leid,
das ihnen angetan worden sei.
Helga, die heute nicht mehr
Koller heisst,
die ehemalige Internatsleiterin.
Sie sitzt über den Akten
der Domino Servite Schule
und hadert mit ihrer Vergangenheit.
Dass ich da
so lange mitgemacht habe.
Von ihr selbst gibt es nur
ein einziges Bild aus dieser Zeit.
Helga T., die ehemalige Frau
von Pfarrer Hans Koller,
dem langjährigen Weggefährten
von Jürg Läderach.
Familie Koller wohnte damals auf dem
Hof, neben dem Knabeninternat.
Helga Koller
war die Internatsleiterin
und hat Kinder
teils massiv gezüchtigt.
Hier ist Helga Koller.
Bei dieser Elternratssitzung haben
Sie auch unterschrieben, dass ...
... dass alles gut sei.
- Genau.
Lieb und ... Ja.
Ich wusste, dass das eine Farce war,
und habe es trotzdem gemacht.
Helga Koller verlor alles,
als sie 2002 den Hof Oberkirch
und ihre Familie verliess.
Vier ihrer Kinder blieben beim Vater,
einzig die kleine Tochter
konnte sie mitnehmen.
Ihr ehemaliger Mann
hat Kaltbrunn damals auch verlassen.
Er predigt bis heute
für Kwasizabantu.
# Gottes Wort ist Wahrheit.
# Ewig bleibt's besteh'n.
# Mögen Berge weichen,
# Völker untergeh'n.
Warum schlugen Sie die Kinder?
Warum taten Sie das?
Ich hab's gemacht.
Ich kann mich hintersinnen,
ich hab's gemacht.
Dafür gibt es keine Entschuldigung.
Ich war einfach in diesem Trott.
Diese Frage
stelle ich mir oft selbst.
Ich hatte ja damals vier Kinder,
als das mit der Schule begann,
das fünfte bekam ich später.
Ich habe die vorher nicht geprügelt,
so wie ich es von da an tat.
Ich habe es einfach gemacht.
Es heisst,
Sie seien die Schlimmste gewesen.
Vielleicht war es so.
Als ehemalige Frau des Pfarrers
und Leiterin des Knabeninternats
war Helga T. Teil des Systems.
Wenn ich da lese,
was die anderen Prediger,
also Läderach und* Piepston *
schreiben,
sich entschuldigen und sagen,
sie hätten davon nichts gewusst
und es täte ihnen leid -
Sie wussten davon
und haben mitgemacht.
Sie sassen mit meinem Mann
in unserem Schlafzimmer,
wenn ein Kind geschlagen wurde,
wo ich nicht alles mitbekam.
Aber sie wussten es.
Sie wissen noch viel mehr als ich.
Wurde die Züchtigung auch gepredigt?
- Ja.
Von allen?
Von allen.
Was heisst das?
- Von* Piepston *und Läderach
und* Piepston *.
Und sie schlugen auch
ihre eigenen Kinder.
Wir konfrontieren die damals
Verantwortlichen mit den Vorwürfen.
"Haben Sie Ihre Kinder gezüchtigt?"
C. M. und Hans Koller
antworten nicht darauf.
W. M. schreibt,
er habe mit seinen Kindern
über Vergangenes gesprochen und
sich für seine Fehler entschuldigt.
Das Ehepaar Läderach und O. V.
verweisen darauf,
dass sie ihre Kinder
mit Liebe und Respekt erzogen
und nicht misshandelt hätten.
Zudem sei in ihrer Gemeinde die
Züchtigung nicht gepredigt worden.
An der Schule und im Internat
soll nach 2002
viel weniger geschlagen worden sein,
sagen Ehemalige.
Joel erinnert sich,
wie es für ihn damals war.
Es gab keine physische Gewalt mehr.
Doch die Hölle
ging dann erst richtig los.
Ich wünschte mir zu dieser Zeit oft,
ich würde wieder geschlagen werden,
weil der Schmerz kurz und heftig
und danach wieder vorbei war.
(Sprechgesang) # Mis Läbe
isch en Kampf, scho vo ganz chli.
# Ha immer ghofft,
es geit gli verbi.
# Ha kämpft, ha mi gwehrt.
# Bi immer i däre Wält gsi,
es isch immer härter worde.
# Doch hüt bin ig wo ig bin.
# Ha immer dra glaubt,
dass es besser cha werde.
# D'Hoffnig stirbt niä,
darum bin ig uf Erdä.
Man hat sich noch einsamer gefühlt,
als man es bis dahin
ohnehin schon tat.
Der Druck war so gross,
dass man sich nicht mehr traute,
gewisse Dinge nur schon zu denken.
Darum habe ich dann für mich
den Sport entdeckt.
Um mich ans Limit zu bringen,
meinen Körper so müde zu machen,
damit ich keine Kraft mehr hatte,
um über anderes nachzudenken.
Das waren die Strafen, die mich
am härtesten getroffen haben:
Wenn man mir die Musik wegnahm
und den Sport verbat.
Das war für mich das Schlimmste.
Denn das war mein Ventil,
mein Rettungsanker.
(Michael B.) Für mich
war es schlimmer als Schläge.
Diese Angst
und auf Stühlen sitzen zu müssen ...
Auf Stühlen sitzen?
- Einfach auf dem Stuhl sitzen,
wie jetzt, jede Pause
oder wann auch immer.
Und sitzen bleiben?
- Ja, sitzen bleiben
und nicht mit anderen sprechen.
Stundenlang?
- Ja, zum Teil.
Nachmittage lang.
Anstatt frei,
musste ich auf dem Stuhl sitzen.
Alles, was so subtil psychisch ist,
das bleibt,
das ist dein innerstes Wesen.
Das bleibt.
Klar, das Schlagen
hat auch einen Einfluss,
wenn du gedemütigt
und klein gehalten wirst.
Aber das Psychische hat mich
kaputt gemacht, mein ganzes Denken.
Muster, die ich bis heute habe.
Joel ist 20 Jahre alt,
als er 2011 ausbricht.
Er möchte uns den Koffer zeigen, den
er damals bei der Flucht dabeihatte.
Es sieht so aus,
alt hätte ich ihn entsorgt.
Ja, er ist fort.
Der ist wirklich nicht mehr da.
Ich hatte es monatelang geplant,
dass ich dann in einer Nacht
mein Zeug packe und verschwinde.
Ich schrieb einen Abschiedsbrief
an meine Eltern,
dass es nicht ihre Schuld sei.
Und dann bin ich zum Fenster raus
und gerannt.
Panisch gerannt.
Im nächsten Ort
fand ich eine Tankstelle,
wo ich mich
hinter einem Container versteckte.
Ich hatte Angst,
dass sie mich zurückholen
und vielleicht einsperren.
Heute denke ich,
das hätten sie wohl nicht getan,
aber meine Angst damals ...
Ich wollte einfach weg.
Die Eltern von Joel
sind mittlerweile auch ausgestiegen.
Und von den zehn Kindern
sind nur noch zwei
in der religiösen Gemeinschaft.
Joels Schwester Eliane hat den Hof
Oberkirch vor einem Jahr verlassen.
Sie, die mit 20 Jahren
von Jürg Läderach
in eine Ehe vermittelt wurde.
Ihr wurde gesagt:
Scheiden sei des Teufels
und führe direkt in die Hölle.
So blieb sie 12 Jahre in einer Ehe,
obwohl diese von Gewalt
und Missbrauch geprägt war.
Es war normal.
Was war normal?
Dass der Ehemann
das mit einem machen darf.
Die Frau muss sich unterordnen.
Mein Körper hat ihm gehört,
da hatte ich nichts zu sagen.
Wenn er ...
Da hatte ich nichts zu sagen.
Das haben sie uns gelehrt.
Das mussten wir tun.
Lange Zeit habe ich das
gar nicht hinterfragt.
Ich suchte lange nach einem Weg,
wie ich das überleben kann
oder wie ich an den Punk komme,
dass ich es gerne
und freiwillig mache
und wir es schön zusammen haben.
Aber das ging einfach nicht.
Eliane schreibt in ihrer Not
den Seelsorgern einen Brief -
an Onkel O., Onkel Jürg und Onkel W.
Sie erzählt ihnen darin
von ihrer Not und fleht sie an:
"Bitte helft mir!
Ich bin gebrochen!"
D.h., die wussten Bescheid, was Sie
in Ihrer Ehe erdulden mussten?
Ja, sie wussten alles.
Zum Teil wussten sie es sogar
ziemlich detailliert.
Wir fragen nach:
Jürg Läderach sagt nichts dazu,
ausser dass er Missbrauch,
Gewalt und Diskriminierung
verurteile.
O. V. und W. M. schreiben:
"Es ist nie eine Frau zu mir
gekommen, die das berichtet hat."
Im Untersuchungsbericht steht,
mehrere Frauen hätten berichtet,
dass sie von ihrem Ehemann
vergewaltigt worden seien.
Eine Frau habe dem Mann jederzeit
zur Verfügung stehen müssen,
sei die verbreitete Lehre gewesen.
Eliane verliess
zusammen mit ihren Kindern
den Hof Oberkirch und ihren Mann
vor einem Jahr.
Als Jürg Läderach davon erfährt,
schreibt er ihr,
dass dies nicht von Gott gewollt sei.
Er werde weiterhin für sie beten.
(Jürg Läderach) Könntest Du bitte,
Herr Jesus, die Gnade schenken,
dass wir unsere Herzen Dir öffnen.
Komm in mein Herz.
Komm in mein Herz, Herr Jesus!
Komm heute in mein Herz.
Und komm, um zu bleiben.
Nicht nur zu Besuch.
Komm, um zu bleiben.
* Chorgesang,
begleitet von Klaviermusik *
Gegenüber SRF
bedauert das Ehepaar Läderach
das unvorstellbare Leid, sie bitten
die Betroffenen um Verzeihung.
Im Untersuchungsbericht
wird an den Schilderungen der Opfer
nicht gezweifelt,
weil verschiedene Personen
unabhängig voneinander
immer wieder gleichartige Szenen
geschildert hätten.
58 Personen haben im Untersuchungs-
bericht anonym ausgesagt.
In unserem Film
haben sich Betroffene gezeigt -
im Wissen,
dass dies Konsequenzen haben könnte:
Wer Unwahres über ihn erzähle,
all jenen hat Jürg Läderach
mit einer Anzeige gedroht.
Eine Anzeige ist bereits vor Aus-
strahlung dieses Films eingegangen.
(M.) Angst machen
gehörte schon immer dazu.
Angst war in dieser ganzen Zeit
das vorherrschende Gefühl.
Und auch jetzt
habe ich wieder Angst.
Der Kanton St. Gallen
als Aufsichtsbehörde
hat aufgrund unserer Recherchen
eine eigene Aufarbeitung
in Aussicht gestellt.
Für die Betroffenen
ein wichtiges Zeichen.
Die Zeit des Schweigens ist vorbei.
Das ist ein zentraler Punkt,
warum ich bei diesem Film mitmache:
Ich möchte nicht,
dass das weiterhin passiert.
Ich würde es schön finden,
wenn es etwas nützt
und Kinder künftig
nicht mehr so behandelt werden.
Untertitelung: Sucevic Solutions
im Auftrag von SWISS TXT - 2023